what's going on there reject nation the
batman comes out so soon with that we
have a new clip and a tv spot first one
is with bruce wayne and alfred that andy
circus debuted on good morning america a
tv spot called it is time drop them both
in the final cut gonna watch them back
to back leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated and keep a look out for our
batman review i think we're gonna get an
early screening not confirmed yet
hopefully we'll have one up by monday a
review that is let's get to it
[Music]
our accounting friends at wayne
enterprises are coming for breakfast
here
why because i couldn't get you to go
there i haven't got time for this it's
getting serious bruce if this continues
it won't be long before you've nothing i
don't care about that
any of that you don't care about your
family's legacy
what i'm doing is my family's legacy
it won't be long before you've nothing
left
[Music]
actually watching them both back to back
quite complimentary yeah yeah yeah it's
like this is what alfred's trying to
warn you about
the bruce listen
if anybody knows the waynes it's out
it's interesting here robert pattinson's
voice in that scene there's a bit of
that like soft menace to the way he
speaks as you're just watching him as
bruce wayne in that moment obviously
with everything we've heard about with
this being year two of batman that he's
uh you know still at that crossroads in
his life where bruce wayne essentially
just only wants to be batman it's kind
of cool hearing like the voice it
complements really well with his voice
that we've heard when he's just batman
like it doesn't sound like he's doing
such a shift is it he is actually sound
like the same person i mean he was
talking about and i know that in the
quote he says like it wasn't that great
of an idea that i was doing this but you
know he talked about doing like the
whispery approach to the batman voice
and i feel like some of that probably
made its way at least into bruce wayne
you know because he seems like a sort of
reserved not uncomfortable guy but a guy
who clearly is very internal and and
lives very internally yeah and then
watching this clip i mean it seems to
just really capture at least like
everything that we've heard andy circus
talk about publicly with this portrayal
of alfred like it's going to be
borrowing from the comics and this is
what any sort of talked about we haven't
i'm not talking any leaks or anything
i'm talking about public information
here like how this version of alfred
will definitely be a person who's from
who's like a former soldier perhaps
somewhere in the secret service at some
point in his life eventually to become a
security officer for thomas wayne i
remember the batman prequel novel but i
think some of that's explored in that
novel then eventually finds his way to
being the butler and then surrogate
father now to bruce wayne and then you
see here in this one clip just in this
like 20 seconds alone that strain in
their relationship those odds that they
are supposedly at in in this movie
alfred is you know he's not equipped to
be a father figure especially one in a
situation like this where bruce wayne is
really headstrong to be this vigilante
for the world of gotham and he's trying
to keep the wayne legacy alive the way
how alfred experienced the wayne legacy
thomas wayne especially with his close
relationship with him and then bruce
wayne wanting nothing to do with that
watching how they're pulling away at
each other so i like that we're gonna
capture them at a different point than
what we're used to with the movies like
i'm a big fan of the gotham show in that
series alfred pennyworth i haven't seen
any of the prequel series that's on fx
but at least in the gotham show that was
on fox you know that was the alfred that
we sort of had it's the the character
who had the military background in that
relationship and taught bruce how to
fight and then had to be a father figure
for him and a mentor of sorts and now
we're seeing that on display here but
where he's actually batman and watching
that divide happen between them which is
very different than what we normally get
with the live action films where he's
you know other than like down the line
with like dark knight rises or something
where alfred is remarkably supportive
and remarkably helpful well yeah it's
the difference between yeah it's like
there's friction occasionally with the
other on-screen outfits but here it
feels like there will be a direct
tension and friction between them as it
seems like at least in this clip alfred
has maybe a greater view of the whole
scope of the picture of both bruce the
wayne legacy how this all fits into
gotham the business side of the you know
wayne enterprises that they still
technically have to deal with and yeah
that abandoned coming from bruce of like
i don't even care about that stuff i
just want to focus on this and alfred's
sort of alluding to the idea that you
kind of have to play both sides you have
to rise to both occasions and find a way
to use both personae because you can't
just leave one by the wayside especially
when you know like the wayne legacy is a
big part of what allows you to batman
yeah and the investors or the financiers
or whoever from wayne indus wayne
enterprises you know like i don't know
if they'll make as big a deal out of
them specifically in this movie but i do
have to imagine that yeah that'll lead
to some significant tension and yeah i
just like that you do get the sense that
he is the surrogate mentor at least uh
rather than the accomplice or rather
than the guy who's like yeah you know
like you said you know kind of always
supportive always like yes bruce until
there's like a particular moment of
emotional anguish where he needs that
extra ounce of guidance i feel like
alfred will kind of be here as almost a
foil throughout for bruce to continue
encouraging him to grow it's cool seeing
just this little clip because already
there you can feel two great actors
providing history within their
performances like i know we were talking
about robert pattinson's voice at first
harkening towards what we've heard him
do when he's in the batman suit but
there's also this other side of me that
kind of interpreted it as like a child
you're watching like the boy bruce wayne
yeah in that moment yeah talking with
like you know my dad yeah
yeah yeah i like seeing alfred as this
sort of like war-torn figure because
every time we see alfred he usually
seems like he's got his [ __ ] together he
knows how to handle this bruce wayne
story i'm uncomfortable when alfred's
here yeah he's really he's really
confident and then here i like how
distraught he is over this whole
situation he's trying to talk to bruce
wayne who was essentially inherited at
him as his own son and here he is just
with like this
sweaty eye makeup from taking off the
cowl and trying to just have a real
conversation with him what's good about
the scene is you could tell that they're
trying not at least alfred is trying not
to fight yeah but it's coming out of him
regardless i gotta be strong and we have
to talk about this but i don't wanna
push you into some kind of direct
conflict yeah it seems like anything
with bruce will be volatile and then
talking about you know the wayne legacy
and then funny enough like i didn't see
this comic to combine it with the tv
spot we were hearing about wayne legacy
and we've seen the trailers you know
explore plenty about how this will
uncover probably perhaps some of the
corrupt dealings that maybe thomas wayne
divulged in just a little bit that's at
least the impression that we've all been
getting so watching him bruce wayne
think like i am doing this in honor of
my family this is why i'm doing this i
am on this vengeance quest because my
family was murdered and then now that
wayne legacy is really going to be
challenged by the likes of someone such
as the riddler yes it's like you're
acting out of the motivation given by
their death but what did their life
stand for and what don't you want to
acknowledge about that perhaps yeah and
i think that makes for some real
powerful storytelling i just feel like
there's going to be a really rich film i
know yeah okay yeah i just can't wait
for it it's gonna be cinema i can't
believe we're gonna let's get this
started so soon we're gonna see this
guys leave your thoughts down below what
did you think about this batman clip did
you already get your tickets are you
going imax dolby cinema
3d
i don't think that exists for this 4dx
4dx three hours of drama
all right guys thanks for being here
we'll talk to you all soon